John is in Tennessee welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show John
oh thank you how are you doing Aviva
better than I deserve sir how can I help
oh yeah just had a quick question for
you a friend of mine actually told me
about your show on YouTube I'm about
$40,000 in debt between myself and my
fiancee and I want I'm trying to figure
something out that I couldn't do to try
to bring it down a little bit better and
look at faster than what we are doing
now I make about 60,000 a year when a
truck-driving but anytime I get any
money saved up we wanted to want to
spending it or blowing it we have two
other people living with us her brother
in our roommate one of them have a job
the other one doesn't have a job at the
time I just want to see if I can get
your opinion on something I couldn't do
on that when you're getting married
haven't decided yet our original point
we've actually been together for about
eight years now my original plan was to
get out of debt before we got married
and I able to chisel it down
why I was afraid to inherit her debt and
she was afraid to inherit my debt it was
kind of stupid I guess
so what does she make a year she
actually just recently got terminated
from her job she was she was actually
driving trucks as well for a few months
but we were at between the two of us
about 140 a year now it's just down to
me for about 60 and she just now got a
job as a CNA making 40 an hour around
there pretty big pretty good yeah it's
pretty major and the fact thing is we
were originally planning on paying our
bills down and we were doing it slowly
when she had that good job and by doing
it slowly it kind of messed us up when
she got terminated that job yeah so um
mmm
why does she not go back and make the
same kind of money for somebody else
that she used to
well they can't go back into trucking at
this point in time if she had a couple
of accidents while she was in the with
her company and when you drive truck
unfortunately there's a thing called
back before it's now I report burger
truck oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
good reason okay
and that's why her that's what her human
nation was over she no longer insurable
yeah yes she was originally going to
work for $11 an hour but got back on
with her an old CNA Chavez had where she
was making $10 an hour but they want her
back so badly they offer 14 yeah okay
all right and how much debt does she
have uh for me I have no she your house
you have 40 how much does she have
between the two of us got 40 how much
they have 12 and so you have 38 or you
have 28 yes I have 28 she has about 12
when you're not married you don't pay
each other's bills so she works on her
12,000 you work on your 28 until you get
married people that don't pay rent don't
get to stay so the guys in there need to
get jobs and they're the parasites need
to you know move somewhere else or get
jobs and pay the rent or they need to
move and then you guys you got to sit
down and develop a plan with your money
on a written budget that says I'm gonna
buy I'm gonna you know pay the rent I'm
gonna buy my lights and water I'm gonna
eat and that's it everything else is
going on this debt till I get it gone
and you can get it gone in a year if you
do that about you yeah but you're on
beans and rice man there's no more
partying there's no more life yeah all
you're doing is getting on all you're
doing is getting on the debt because you
told me what you're doing you told me I
screw it off I get money and then it
just goes and I go buy something
and then but the
you're not allowed to whine about not
getting out of debt if you keep living
like that yeah you got to be it's got to
be game on I mean it's a pretty simple
formula it's like you know you get in
the truck and you have a destination you
put that in the GPS and you're either
going to follow that or you're not going
to get to the destination right correct
the same thing with this you're either
going to take these steps or you're not
gonna get out of that and so you got to
go I'm done being impulsive I'm done you
know this money just slipping away every
month I'm gonna eat barely and I'm not
going out to eat ever and I'm gonna pack
my lunch in the cooler in the truck and
we're gonna live on nothing no life
because I'm work too dadgum hard to be
this broke I mean you get sick and tired
but you know you get sick and tired of
being sick and tired that's what turns
it around for you yeah you do all that
you can do and I would suggest that if
you're gonna get married that it's time
to get married it's time to paint or get
off the ladder dude I mean eight years
really it's time decide what you're
gonna do here how you gonna live your
life and you cuz y'all just been playing
footsie with every little part of this
and you really need to decide this is
who we are this is what we're doing and
you know it's it's adults devise a plan
and follow it children do what feels
good and I've been right there where you
are I've done Dumber things and you're
doing I've lived more impulsively than
you're living I used to think when you
went to Sam's or Costco that the cover
charge was 200 bucks I thought you had
to buy something in there right I
thought it was federal law you had to
buy nine gallons of mustard or they
didn't let you out right I thought you
had to spend everything you made and I
bought stuff that I didn't even know
what it was I understand I understand
what impulsive feels like I'm being
broke feels like and I finally just said
no I'm done I've had it I'm not living
like this anymore
and you got to have that moment sir